nouvelle manifestation en france devant
le ministère du logement à l'appel de
l'association droit au logement une
mobilisation intitulée raffut de noël
pour interpeller la ministre emmanuelle
wargon sur les conditions de vie des
personnes sans domicile fixe pour en
parler on retrouve tout de suite notre
reporter estelle farges qui se trouve
sur place
et celle bonjour alors dites nous quel
est l'objectif de ce raffut de noël
et bien l'objectif nadège c'est de faire
du bruit le jour de noël objet de c'est
l'objectif de ce rassemblement à
l'initiative de l'association adala
droit aux log chance au logement ce
qu'il réclame et bien c'est tout
simplement l'application à des lois ce
sont leurs mots par exemple
l'application de la loi dalo qui permet
notamment aux personnes mal logées
d'être reconnus prioritaires pour faire
valoir leur droit à un logement est
digne il réclame aussi la réquisition
des logements vides ou encore le
financement de la construction de
logements sociaux je propose d'écouter
est la porte parole du dal ile de france
on nous demande à la ministre ben c'est
d'appliquer la loi dalo loi de davos et
l'hébergement à traditionnel jusqu'à
leur logement et puis là des conditions
dignes parce que le problème s'est noyé
quand même des conditions que c'est
forcément très évidente pour les gens on
demande qu'elles construisent plus de
logement social à des coûts de loyer qui
peuvent qui peut permettre le relogement
de bus plus grand nombre donc voilà est
aussi belle se voyait apportant parce
qu'aujourd'hui partout même dans le
logement s'élève pour les revendications
sachez que plus de trois millions de
logements seraient vacants en france
selon l'association droit au logement
mais c'est el farj merci pour ces
précisions